well now it's a question the government
and the Labour Party is still tiptoeing
around does leaving the EU also mean
leaving the single market while the
former shadow home secretary and
Manchester mayoral hopeful Andy Burnham
thinks it should and he joins me now
very good morning to mr. Burnham and get
on to that in just one minute but I just
want your instant reaction to this news
about all grieve now you've been amongst
those campaigning for a public inquiry
into or greed it seems that's not going
to happen but we're going to get some
kind of release of the many documents I
suspect that the police forces the
various police forces involved have held
you welcome that Oh certainly and its
credit to a vet Cooper and the Home
Affairs Select Committee who have
carried on pressing the home secretary
so this is a positive development I
can't see how any government can deny
people the truth about what happened and
as I've repeatedly said Dermot we won't
have the full truth about Hillsborough
until we also know what happened five
years earlier after or grief because in
my view the same police force use the
same tactics it tried to blame the
miners in the same way it would later
try to blame the Liverpool supporters
okay so briefly on that you think the
charge of a public inquiry is still
alive well I think it's got to be
because we need to see what these files
reveal and if they reveal evidence of
wrongdoing both in the police force or
possibly within the government of the
day then that will need to be looked at
further so yes I think this is a
positive development and as I say it's
credit to affect Cooper in the Home
Affairs Select Committee okay thanks for
that now on to the single market isn't
it party policy that the UK tries to
remain within this single market you
think actually leaving it might be good
for the north well I think to understood
them at things are getting very confused
aren't they the government isn't setting
out its plans and so many people out
there are still rerunning the referendum
campaign I think what's got to happen
people have got to go back to what the
public voted for and here in Greater
Manchester people quite clearly voted
for a change to the current freedom of
movement rules that is that is the
starting point it seems to me in this
debate and what I am saying is let's
have a brexit plan that works for
way to Manchester that means it must
respond to what people voted for so I
would argue that does need to be a
system that offers more control but it's
got to be balanced we want to continue
to welcome people from around the world
to work here but that's our starting
point the single market can't be our
starting point because that in the end
here was not what people voted on so
just what do you have in mind because
you know we've been hearing from labor
for an awful long time now the
acceptance of a need for some kind of
controls on immigration could you be
more explicit for us then does it
involve visas permits point system what
the government has got to set out its
intentions but I believe we could have a
system that is more linked to people
coming to fill a specific job in the
labor market rather than speculative
free movement which has actually caused
some quite difficult challenges in parts
of Greater Manchester we've seen
pressure downward pressure on wages now
the public are right to raise concerns
about that Dermot so we need a system
that affords greater control that allows
us to bring people to work here and
contribute to our economy in our society
but also deals with the negative effects
of full free movement which has been
downward pressure on wages but also
pressure on primary schools GP services
we need a system that balances those
things together and that's what I'm
calling for is it because you're
intending to be leaving Parliament I
guess if you win the mayoral tea that
you feel free now to talk out so openly
against party policy against what the
leader says if you look back actually
over a long time I've been making these
arguments I made these arguments in
cabinet when I was picking up concern
about the way free movement was working
back in the the latter part of the last
decade and when I stood for the Labour
Party leadership both times I made
similar arguments you know I'm not
somebody who says yeah we just abandon
our relationship with Europe certainly
not and I hoped that we may be able to
reform free movement from within the EU
but the public have said otherwise
they've asked us to reassess our
relationship with the European Union
particularly on this question of free
movement you know it hasn't been working
for parts of Greater Manchester as I
just said so what we need to do is start
there except the public's call for a
system of more control but balance that
by securing maximum access to the single
market what is your analysis as you as I
say you hope to turn your back on the
Labor Party nationally as someone said
become the Boris of the North I know you
you're not going to accept that but what
do you read into these two by-elections
recently in sleaford and in Richmond
where the Labour Party's been hammered
in a massively remained constituency and
then hammered again in one that was
overwhelmingly leave do you fear that
the party nationally is no longer
relevant no I don't fear that labour has
got a huge role to play going forward
standing up for for working people being
a party that speaks for fairness what
we've got to do though is respond to the
times we're living through we are living
through it feels to me like something of
a political earthquake where there is a
major backlash going on against our
centralized Westminster system of
government Westminster in my view has
failed large parts of the north of
England you know it led our traditional
industry go without giving us any real
help it's focused on selling off council
housing rather than building the new
homes that we need and it's given us a
housing crisis and it's failed to offer
hope to young people now people at the
referendum were calling for change on
all of those things and they were also
saying you haven't been listening to us
about the way free movement is affecting
affecting us so this is a moment of real
change I think Dermot where we need to
embrace devolution to the english
regions and it to be quite proper for me
to argue for what benefits greater
manchester and that might be different
from what what people say at a national
level but it's just because you're a
seasoned campaigner you know what it
comes down to on the doorstep and you
will have heard this from the Labour
canvases in sleaford they say they were
knocking on door steps of people who
previously voted labour and they were
saying are you remain or leave what is
party policy your canvas is had to say
well it's more nuanced than that and
people just went and it seemed didn't
vote for labour and as you know from the
British elections survey didn't you that
more people now align them sell
as a remainder or a lever than they do
with political parties this is a real
problem for labor what we've got to make
sense don't we do with all the times
that we're living through and I don't
think people want us to be in the lib
dem position of trying to reopen the
referendum what labour has got to do is
find a balanced approach to brexit and
as I say a brexit here that works for
greater manchester and I think maybe
Labour's problem has been over the last
15 20 years is we've tried to run a
single line to apply to the whole of the
UK and the problem with that is things
look different here from great dimension
than they do in London and that's why
this change is important now that it's
right that I can articulate how people
here feel and develop a response that is
right for people here and that shouldn't
in any way threaten the if you like that
the National the National Party and so
that's the change I think we need to
move towards and I'm quite clear that we
need to look at brexit and what it means
for greater manchester in a different
way because there's a balance also about
the single market it may well be the
best answer for the north of England to
stay in the single market but we also
need to think about do we need more
flexibility on state aid rules to help
rebuild our industrial base and it's
those trade-offs I think we need to
debate just very briefly if you win the
mayoral t you're going to stand down as
an MP for me and that it said might go
to you keep your seat in that
by-election well that's a that's a lot
of assumptions there there is no there
is no haven't won and there's no vacancy
at the moment but I I do hear that mr.
Nuttall talk is talking of parachuting
himself into to this area well to be
honest I think that's part of what is
wrong with politics people don't like
the idea that people use seats as a
place of convenience for them you know
they want to see people who who come
from the area that they that they
represent but mr. nuts all is also an
advocate of privatization in the
National Health Service i look forward
to him explaining and justifying those
views on the on the streets of lee and
in the middle of town so you are going
to stand down we're right to be
successful next year of course I
wouldn't seek to do
two jobs that would not be right but
that is some way in the future you know
I'm not taking anything for granted what
I am saying is if I want to represent
greater manchester then we need to start
dealing with what people here was saying
at the referendum and that's what I'm
focused on okay well thanks very much
mr. Burnham very good to talk to you
Andy burn thank you